[Music]
all right here we go welcome to another
exciting episode of Kos and I always
like to start off today with um a Samba
note rest in peace to Lourdes whisky
he was the Iron Chef he made sure that
all the iron Lords was well fed on the
refrigerators and the coverage of stock
with food when we went on our trips to
California to e3 and loving memory I
hope and pray I send you off right with
these statues so without further ado
we're gonna do it way big
I bring you sideshows Hulk vs. Wolverine
and iron Studios juggernaut vs.
Wolverine boom right there also told you
format a change is ever-evolving
ever-changing but I bring you these two
statutes just to let you know that um I
respect strength and nothing embodies
strength like The Incredible Hulk which
is my favorite character you will see I
have plenty of statues of the Incredible
Hulk I will do like a 30 days of
Incredible Hulk I think I have enough
statues to cover 30 days of Incredible
Hulk statues different ones um and you
know I have some Wolverine statues and
the juggernaut I cannot wait to collect
more sideshow has a juggernaut statue
that's coming out and also it is a lot
of
someone's it's out there if I can snatch
him up I'll get him I'm also looking at
a lot of custom hulks that I can
actually purchase all right so when
we're going into the detail of these two
statues this is gonna be our first
episode of vs. so we're gonna have
sideshow versus iron studios and which
statue did it better so we're gonna
start off with the sideshow Hulk vs.
Wolverine as you can see in the Hulk vs.
Wolverine that the detail on the Hawks
back arms shoulders chest biceps all the
muscle structure in the Hulk is
impeccable 100% like a super bodybuilder
like you would envision the Hulk to be
then you'll also see Wolverine is highly
detailed and you know down to the boots
the boots have treads on it in the back
the claws are very sharp I noticed on
this statue that the calls are very
sturdy and it comes with a switch out
head I choose to display the head that
he I was initially showed up in and I
think it's a Hulk 180 and he actually
full release in Hulk 181 I remember
reading a book like it was yesterday
I would love to get a Hulk vs. Sasquatch
whoever's listening please make that
that is like one of my greatest fights
or Hulk vs the Windigo
same thing with Wolverine versus the
Windigo please and we'll reverse the
Sasquatch please make that but um as you
can see the wood on the base as the Hulk
is fighting and he steps on a tree he
snaps a tree in half you would think
that's a log but no that is a redwood
that he has snapped in two
the base has wood and rock and soil you
can see the dirt on the Hulk's feet you
can see his handprints like you can see
intricacies inside his hands Wolverines
claws his armor on his soup and then
we're gonna take it over to iron studios
where you can see they're fighting on
the steps of the X
men's mansion and juggernaut is coming
in and Wolverines trying to stop him
from getting inside the building and the
juggernaut is smashing the steps trying
to get to his dead stepbrother Professor
Xavier now a lot of people think that
the juggernaut is a mutant he is not a
mutant he has got his powers from the
crimson gems of cyttorak you might have
heard Doctor Strange used that in the
last Avengers movie those are the bands
that he wrapped around Thanos I was at
the crimson bands of cyttorak it's a god
and he imbued his champion with his
powers or a piece of his power and that
is the juggernaut he is unstoppable once
he gets going there's a lot of times at
the Hulk and the juggernaut has fought
the Hulk is world breaker used the
juggernauts momentum to toss him around
and one fight I think the juggernaut
actually beat the Hulk but he didn't
know who the juggernaut was because he
was out of costume on a uniform and you
know he fought professor Hulk and he's
supposed to be the smartest person in
the world right how come he didn't know
was jugging out really how many big men
is running around like that and can
fight it was it was a stupid issue but
regardless to what this statue is
impeccably detailed you can see the wood
snapping through the flaws you can see
Wolverine leaping now the Wolverine on
the iron Studios is less detailed than
the Wolverine is on the sideshow see I
believe that the sideshow Wolverine is
as equally detailed as the halt whereas
where we have the juggernaut which is
tremendously detailed you can look
inside his helmet and seen Kane Marcos
face like his grimace like he's trying
to get to Wolverine but here's how I
earn Studios makes up the difference
what they choose to do is they give you
a switch out head so you get different
portraits and they give you switch out
hands so this is the first time I can
display bone claws so those who know
Wolverine has went through a process to
get his antimatter in claws that didn't
know
he wasn't born with him he wasn't born
when I until my time in the skin he was
dissected and he was worked on in a lab
and he had originally bone claws and
they grafted the entire matting on top
of the bone claws so the bone claws are
really sharp and he uses that to fight I
don't know how the hell he's gonna fight
the juggernaut with bone claws but
whatever right but I'm gonna choose to
display it that way why because when it
shipped this statue is incredibly
fragile I broke one of the claws on the
Wolverines anti Miriam claws so I'm
gonna to display him with the bone claws
they are highly sensitive that's the
only drawback in this statue I can
believe that I see a lot of Wolverine
statues you have you have to be very
careful of the claws if they don't like
weld them into the hand and mold it as
one piece it's gonna be a lot of
problems and they decided to mold them
singly and put them on and you know now
I have to get glue I have to work on it
and you have to get special type of glue
so it is what it is but these are two of
the heaviest statues that I have there
are two of the best statues I have these
are Dominus though and Rama's moon means
that there's a fight scene or a scene
depicting two statues or more than one
statue and the Dora Rama and this is
what I choose to show I chose to choose
to show you the biggest baddest and some
of the highly anticipated ones that I
was looking forward to once I put my
pre-orders in I couldn't wait to get
these statues the moment I saw them go
for pre-order and I'm proud to display
them for you god bless good luck thank
you for tuning in to another Wednesday
Kos I can't believe that this is you
know happening is a reality and I'm so
happy and I'm so blessed that I am able
to share my world with you
I'll also log into a Lords of gaming
dotnet where we have the latest
up-to-date videos this week we go to pax
you have our
editorial pieces you have gaming moves
latest gaming news
you also have latest trends and you also
have a lot of opinion pieces so you're
not gonna get the same regurgitator
stuff that you get in other sites come
check us out and also don't forget to
like follow and subscribe and watch iron
Lords podcasts Sundays at 1:00 p.m. see
you soon
we won't be there this week because
we'll be at PAX but we'll be live every
day for you by the way stay tuned to
keep watching all the pictures that I
upload and also you get to watch
beautiful videos without this guy
talking
[Music]